it's been a few a few years since we've
seen each other right
it has been a few years i can't see you
at all i see a big bright screen that
says
i look hot i look so good right now
you are missing is there any way only on
with someone else's hair neal but it's
fine um
i almost wore that yeah you'd probably
look better you jerk
um so wait i actually just celebrated 18
years
since idol and it made me think of you
because i remember you telling me
because somebody was talking about a
moment like this
that people use it for weddings a lot
and i was like i remember neil telling
me that
did was that y'all's dance was that the
song that you was our
first dance song that was our song kelly
clarkson
we don't have many people in our lives
that we talk like 13 year old school
girls about
and it's it's you are one of them and
and you're that song we met during i
think season
two of american idol when and it was
still this giant juggernaut and i think
that your song that song was was playing
a lot and was still connected with and
so
we were falling in love at that same
time and the lyrics to that song always
kind of stayed with us
and we always said you know if we ever
got married that would be a great
first dance song especially with you
guys
people wait a lifetime for a moment like
this some people search forever for that
one special kiss it was so
it was so perfect and our parents were
there and we got to dance with them i
love your smile you're like reliving it